me
うん
よそういうことで今日のお昼ご飯です宮
goota のデミハンバーグ面
car
なんか白いあの城ケダね画面
今尾ひれなんで消しましたなんかメインの上にハンバーグが塗ったっていうマジキチ
いや駄目ですが麺の上にハンバーガーに乗ってるっていう
すごい
新しい
カップ麺なんですよね何な
何が弱点かって言ったらめっちゃもごめんってちょっと長めなんで渡航
急いでの人にとっちゃね
大変なことになります
これめっちゃ上手くなったよし御待ちます
もういいでしょ
おおすごい見た目はそんなおかしいなぁ
やっぱりなんかねにハンバーガーが入っていうのはちょっと粋な気分がします
食べますねぇ
まずはベンダー食べます
もう面でだいたい高圧面でだいたい賞馬期末ネオ
命はちょっと薄めですねけど美味しいです*系の
なんだろうこれパン鍛錬た感じですこれとハンバーガー合わせて食ったらおいしい
パターンですね
ざーさんの肉食べます
あ最近日焼けしたって言われるけど多分日焼けしました
やはり春っていうのは一番紫外線が強いて聞くんだよ
なんかたぶん
外出るだけで日焼けするタイプなんですよね
なんか面よりハンガー減税も僕面のほうがいいですよ無理やり物クラスた感があります
なと
発想は良いと思うんですけど
もうん
もうは一方もう一個上を目指してほしかった
現像に満足しても少なかったんだ
美味しいですけどハンバーグと名誉もうちょっとこう
ね自然な関係にもっていけたらいいと思います
やっぱり合コンで出会った発布療法
年功無理やり感があってなんか違うんですよ
やっぱ
普通に恋愛してほしかった値段忘れたんですけど
コンビニとかで売ってるんだよぜひ皆さんに
合コンで出会ったらこうなりますっていうのをこの面を通して
胸に刻んでほしいですねじゃあ
げーっ
tan
ん